you know me I'm a TV junkie and if
you're a TV junkie like me you're very
excited about this one of my favorite
shows just started again season five of
the American oh yeah that's a man that's
really like you like that show it is and
now it's like it it's like the world is
tailored for exactly I know I know
reality is copying our yeah no it's an
amazing show it's fantastic I'm so glad
that there are new episodes okay who
just said ha tis I who just said huh
by the end of this sentence it will have
been I who I said ha a total of four
times ah okay I'm sorry
sir why are you saying ha because
compared to my favorite show the
Americans is more like the Americans
okay sir based on your outfit I think I
can guess what your favorite chili it is
a show that pits brother against brother
in a magical realm of sex and fire yes
we we now thunderous smash hit that has
captured America's imagination and then
brought it to feverish orgasm okay I
guess that's one way to put it yes Shh
do you hear that Conan the howl of the
wind something is coming and it starts
with the W yes we all know winter is
coming winter
may I am speaking of burgers
whoa burgers the reality show about Mark
Wahlberg's family running a burger joint
in Boston is that the show you're
talking about which I speak it is
without exaggeration the single greatest
thing TV show or otherwise to have ever
been created by the human race ever
without exaggeration ever okay wait a
minute tell us why is it so good what's
so great about it the question isn't why
is it so good the question is it is so
good every week a bunch of people who
are somewhat related to Mark Wahlberg
shout at each other well at least one of
them is cooking a cheeseburger oh great
yeah all right fine fine I'm still not
sold on wall burgers I'm sorry fine
don't take my word for it there's
someone very special here tonight who I
think just might convince you ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Mark Wahlberg
hi Conan okay so your last name is Mark
Wahlberg that's your whole last name
that's right okay are you related to
Mark Wahlberg
no why would I be related to him Mark
Wahlberg's last name is Wahlberg my last
name is Mark Wahlberg yes I guess I'm an
idiot for asking anyway I'm just here to
tell you that wall burgers is a very
good show and you should check it out
and you should also check out my student
Leslie's drawings he's one of my best
art students you're the best art teacher
my son Mark Wahlberg
wait a minute your name is Leslie that
appears to be the case Conan would you
like to see one of my drawings all right
yeah whatever let's take a look at one
of Leslie's drawings sure yeah no
problem we are I call this one I call
this one sexy dinosaur okay I don't know
a lot about art but that is terrible
so Conan have I convinced you that wall
burgers is a great show of course you
have it you've just wasted my time with
a drawing that's all you've done well I
know someone who might be able to
convince you please welcome mark
hi mark I had a really nice time last
night oh great me too now do you agree
that wall burgers is a great show no all
you did was bring out a guy dressed as a
narwhal so no fair enough then I think
it's time we brought out the man of the
hour now no one now the only now mark
[Music]
this has been a huge waste of time here
a waste of time
there you have it tonin I've proven that
wall burgers is a fantastic show no you
have not and if you're not a Game of
Thrones fan why the hell you dress like
that oh this is what I wear to sex
parties to the sex party
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time we'll never have that
you